firebase is a platform from google for
creating mobile and web applications in
this course from cybernautico you will
learn how to use firebase features and
integrate firebase with different
javascript frameworks
firebase a suite of tools needed to
build a full stack application
with authentication
databases
file storage
security rules and analytics to build a
full stack right application
with easy to use documentation
so by the end of this video
we will be able to learn authentication
in firebase
how to use databases
file image storage uploads and real-time
database updates
firebase queries and at the last i will
learn how to host an application to
firebase
we will also learn how to use firebase
with different frameworks like react
javascript next or angular
so let's start now
so first of all let me create one
project in firebase
let me enter firebase
front end
continue
so i am showing you from the start from
the beginning how to do all of these
here i have a quote signed box which has
two inputs email and password
and let's tackle authentication first
so here
we have so many options like
password email authentication email link
google sign in
with apple
with facebook twitter github microsoft
yahoo and all
so let me show you these things first
now our project has been created
now let's create one app so click web
app here
enter the name
so wait a second
make this says
firebase basics
then registered app
yes so here i have a line in email input
and password input
and one submit button
if we type anything here this will be
fed into this
email of name sorry in the input of name
with the value respectively so for the
email it will be email in this data
state
for password it will be password
so we have to install firebase first
so to install firebase come here
and go to this file just add firebase
as dependency like this
it will be added and for react app for
the vs code i mean you have to install
using this command
npm install firebase now you see we are
getting all this data here
that we have to import in the app into
this app.js
so create a file here here fire
base
config.js
let's put all the things here copy these
things and just paste here
let me remove the commands to make it
more clear
we have to export this const app
so this is the config data we have api
key auth domain id and all
so we have to input it here
so import
app
from
one step back the file name firebase
config
so now we can use firebase for this app
here
so continue to console
let's okay we are targeting
authentication first so we have to
come to authentications tab click get
started here
it's come with it comes with the so many
type of authentications that i shown you
here
password email link google facebook and
all
so we have to enable them first so let's
first enable
email and password sign up
and sign in
also add your domain here so let me add
the domain the domain is this
so copy this and just add it here
wait a sec
add it
so it will work
i guess now what we have to do is
we have to
uh import a few things from firebase
authentication
so just like it says here
import get auth and create user with
email and password
here
so get get auth is a function to check
whether we are authenticated or not
and
this function create user with email and
password
it is it is used to create one user
so let me do it
first let me define the auth instance so
let auth
equals to get auth
simply
like this
then in this function handle submit if
you click the button here submit button
this will be sent inside
if we click the submit button this one
this function will run
which is handle submit
so in this function of create user with
email and password we have to pass
the three things first is the auth
see it's getting passed here the auth
the email and the password
so let me get the email so our email is
from the data state
so data.email
or i mean and data.password
password
so we have to record the response in the
console so we will use then
it will send us a response
to add the response in the params
in the callback function
we can just say console.log
response dot user
but if it fails ever sign in fails we
can just cache it
using cache so error we will just show
an alert which is error not message
to save it
now let's try to sign in
we don't have an email here so let's try
it now
enter the email or first open the
console and clear all these things here
from the console
add the email and some password
submit
see we are getting all this data here
provider reloader okay we don't need
this we only need the
access token we need the display name
original email that we used to sign up
is verified
phone number and all so here it's not
verified
so if we face this
we should see this email here see it's
coming here
and one great thing about this is so let
me sign in or sign up i mean
with the same email twice
it's present here
if we sign up again or create the user
again we will see an error in the alert
submit
see we're writing auth email already in
use
so that's how we create a user in the
firebase firestore
so
not fires what i mean in the auth
i am getting
why i am repeating firestore every time
i speak firebase
okay so creator is done now let's see
how to sign in
so to sign in
we have this method sign in with email
and password
so simply add it here already place the
create user and
here also
and all the other things will be the
same
save and now let's try to sign in with
this email
clear it
the console clear
submit
see we're getting all the data here
which
is getting returned from here from this
response
but if we enter the wrong email that's
not present here we should see an error
so let me use an wrong email mission 440
at the rate 4401 at the gmail.com and
click submit
see
user not found because this user is not
present inside the auth
what if we enter the wrong password so
let's enter the wrong password
submit see still the error of wrong
password we are getting here
so sign up and sign in is done i mean
create account and sign in
so now let me focus on the email
or google sign in authentication
so you can read the docs and do it just
like i'm doing it for all other
sign in methods because
i won't be able to show you show you
everything
so last here is let me just show you
google of provider first
so we need the get auth and google
provider
then we have to create the auth instance
for provider of google so let google
provider
equals to new we have to initialize the
provider using new new
google as provider
fine
then we have to
import one more thing which is called
sign in with pop-up
pop-up pop-up it's here
so we have three things get auth google
provider and
sign in with pop-up
we have to use the function here
and we will pass
the auth this auth and the provider name
which is google
and that's all
but here also we have to we have to
provide the provider of google
so enable this and then
save using your
email at the email support id
project support email
save
so it's been created so save and
affiliate submit button here this should
open up a pop-up here
so if we just save and try
okay it's it will work
see the name of nishant as 440.
gmail.com
the provided here is email
so if we try again
click submit
okay okay okay
so we are getting an error because we
have to
add the method here
but this is not working this custom
domain
so let me fix this
so so so if i just
copy this
and add this here or just
do a share button
okay it's not for ours okay just copy
the web link here
from here and just post it here in the
domain
click
add
and that should work now
so if we click submit button okay on
authorized domain
wait a second submit once more
okay what is the problem here
we can't able to trigger this
here so submit or refresh this then
click submit
okay now we are reading it here let me
show you the pop-up
and i think you can see it too
so then just click ok where is it click
the email any email
so
see we are getting returned all the data
here that we
got previously for the password sign up
the email
so this email is verified
because we have used
the email sign up
sorry we have used the google signup i
mean and the provider here has been
changed to google
so similarly we have github
we have facebook
apple twitter and all so for github
we have to
uh import the github provider and then
we have to
add the
what is it um let me just
open the sign method of github
github
we have to add the client id and secret
and it will return us the auth handler
or seller link that we have to paste in
the github website
data map i mean
so if you go to github.com
we should see
the settings here so go to settings
and go to the developer settings here
pause apps so create a new app here so
let me just open this fire auth
so i have to use the
authorized layer
that you are getting from here
where here we are there where from here
wait a second if we add the github
this one so we have to add this here in
this
uh
authorization authorization callback url
then we have to get the client id in
secret from here so you have to figure
it out
if you're not
if not you can check my video about data
authentications in the same playlist
so
that's done
so we have done google authentication
and password
create user and create
user and sign in
so now let's move to
databases
so for firestore let me just go to
this
uh
cloud fire store then
okay we don't need this you can redox if
you want but i will show you how to
perform all the four operations for
firebase firestore
so open the firestore here in the left
tab
then just create database
start in test mode
then enable this so now we can use cloud
firestore
and here in the firebase config we have
to import a thing called
so import
uh get fired store so wait let me just
first
add the firebase slash firestore
folder we have to import
get firestore
from
from firebase firestore
then we have to create one new const of
database
then we have to pass
this app in the get firestore
function so we are done
also we have to import the database in
our app
dot js because we have to use it to
create the reference to a collection
so see we have to create a collection
here so we can do it manually here or
from the application from react app
so let me do it from the react app so we
have to remove all these things that we
don't need right now
this
let me name of this as well from auth we
have to import
two things
the first is the wait collection keyword
collection function to add a collection
to firebase
then add doc
to add document to the firebase
firestore
so we can do from
wait what i'm doing firebase
slash
firestore
this so let's create a collection here
so just type
const
collection
ref
equals to collection keyword it will
take the things
here which first is the database
the database this database second the
collection name so we can make the
collection as
users the name users will be here
in the collection
it will be shown later
now i have to send data using add doc
function
to add doc
and it accepts params first is the
collection reference
and second is the data so let me add one
more okay live
claim it so just add email
it will be
data.email
then
let's add the password
data.password
fine then we have to record our response
or we can just say
dot then for the success
alert
and we can say alert
data added
but if it is an error we can just catch
it and say
error
we can say
console
or alert
alert a r r dot message
so save it
now let's try to add data so let me
enter the email
and some password
submit
this function like add dog collection
uh it will be it's common in all the
frameworks like react angular so we have
if we have to add data
from angular we have to use ad doc
if we have to add data from uh what is
it swelt or
javascript or
react or
view js or next yes we have to use that
doc so it's common for all other
frameworks
so see this new data is now here this
new collection name
nishanth s440 address
and the password let me add one more
so let me just make it as one and submit
added and it's here
if we refresh this page i think it
should be here
so let's check
see we have two collections here now
nishanth has four further one the latest
one and this one the previous one
now let's see how to read data
so we can create a function
for this so const
get data
it will be an error function
so to get data we have to get a function
called
get docs
this function gets data from firebase
to get data we have to just pass the
collection reference here so collection
ref
we have to pass it here
it returns some data as a response like
any api call
so say response
and here we can just do
console.log
wait
response
dot data
we have to map through the data because
it's very
clumsy
so it takes a parameter called let's say
item
then we have to return
uh what we have to return return item
dot data or
doc
let me make this data we will see what
we get
so we have to call the function because
we are not calling it
so if we paste it here in the submit
button we should see the
data here if we click submit
so cannot write property of map
okay i guess this is not data it's dock
we can check it here if we go to red
data
get data once
okay okay
okay okay okay get doc okay this is not
the data it's only for
one data
okay region let's check add and manage
data i think
the red is already here
so where it is read it redox
[Music]
okay wait
picture data let me see
okay leave it let's try this
submit
cannot read property as of
okay i think this is doc
and this one is data
submit it save it submit it
then
um
cannot read properties of
what for for map
so we are passing the collection
reference and get docs
and then we are consoling the response
response.docs i think it's not
doc
submit yes now we're writing this
we're adding two objects here which are
these objects these two ids
so let's add the id as well so wrap it
in a curly bracket
and
make it and spread operator
so it's storing the data and also the id
so id will be
item dot id
save it and now let's try
if we don't need it
okay we don't need three brackets here
because
it's just an
single string so try it now
submit
see it said the two objects
with their ids this id and this id
so this is how very document so let's
now try to update data
so const
update doc we need a function update
data
so these are common
i am telling you once more
to add the function to the summit button
of update data function
so here
we have to
import two things so we can just add
if we
break this down it will be good for us
so we have to do a dock and
update talk
so we can update only one data at a time
so in the update dock we have to send
the button we have to send the id
so you can send id
i mean because we didn't need the id
here
so let me just choose any id here from
this two
and i will show you and for the depth
you can
see my other exact video where i have
shown how to update data using the id
param
it's just a common react thing
not from firebase so what we can do is
we have to use
the dock function so best we have to
specify which document to update so say
const
dock
to update
equals to
we have to use this dock function that
we just imported
it takes three parameters so
two of them are here
where
let me check
this collection reference
with this one
so it is the database and the user
so pass it here
the database the collection name and the
id so let me choose the id of this
so this one copy this id we will update
this field then statically
so add the id here so now
okay so doc is now been selected which
is recommend to update
so if we choose the submit button click
submit button here
this nishant has 440 and the password of
one two three four five six will be
updated then we have to call update doc
to update it
we will pass doc to update i mean which
document to update
and the new data
so let's add email this should be
let's say abc and add password something
anything one two three
one two three four five fine
so if it is successful we can just call
then
which will
show an alert and it will say
data
updated
but if it fails we can catch it using
catch error
and just an alert
and it will say
error dot message
fine so this is done
we are passing database the collection
name and the id here
in the doc
to update function
and then we are doing all these things
save it
okay let's also
uh call let's get data function
okay that is not important
so click submit so let me check first
the email is this okay the email is this
it will be changed to this abc
the password is this change to one two
three four five so submit
update it and if you check here
see the email is abc and the password is
one two three four five six
if we add this id here
let me show you
and we can all we can also update one
field at a time so if we don't want to
update password we can just remove this
or make this just as anything you want
or simple
some password so save
submit so here
there should be abcd so let me make it
abcd
this should be abc it is an email
so submit
updated
see the email is now abcd and the
password is the same
so that is how we update document so the
fourth one is delete document so let me
show you here
so we can make it delete data
and pass the function here
to the button
and we don't need to pass data here we
only need to
pass the dock to update or dock to
delete
so let me get one more function which is
known as
delete dock
or delete
docker
doc
fine so just add the function here
where
in the
okay update doc please so we have to use
the data deleted alert
so all the things are fine so same and
now let's check
if we click submit
second id will be deleted this one with
email abcd and the password one two six
submit
okay deleted and see it's not here we
only have one
field with the email of abc and the
password of this so that's how delete
function works
if you want to delete this id
we have to copy the id and paste it here
so
the third parameters id here
so you have to get the id from the
params
for this delete function
pass the id from here it will be come
here it will come here and then pass the
id simply here
so submit
deleted
and see we don't have any fields here we
are having empty data in firestore
so that's how a document get document
update document and delete document
works in firebase firestore all the four
cred operations operation
now let's see file storage
for firebase storage
so we have to do
here import
wait a second
from
uh firebase storage
storage come come come come it's coming
here okay
so it should be
get storage
from firebase storage
then we have to export a constant so
export const
storage equals to get storage
and similarly pass the app
then import the storage here
so we don't need the database
because
we are going to remove these things
to make it clean
remove this
remove this okay don't remove this
remove handle summit
not the function just the
constants remove
get data delete data and all
and here let me create
one
give it a second first
make it handle submit here
let me create one input field
so we don't need this so remove it
and on on change it takes an event and
we will call the idle input function for
this
so
we can just set it like this as well so
set data
this should be event
dot target dot files
and zeroth index so the file will be
stored here in the handle input
and then if we see in the
storage let me open the storage here
click web click
click
upload files
so we are getting the data here
let me show you ultimately so
console.log
let me say
file here
so file will be here
okay not this we don't have to use file
i'm doing this wrong we have to use data
so
handle input
okay then we also don't need this so
just paste it here
remove handle limit function
so if we choose one file or just save it
but but but the thing is we have to add
the type
so type will be file
we don't need placeholder in the
name so remove them
so if we choose one file
they should appear in the
of sign if this should appear
here if we say if we press the button of
submit
so let me choose one file here like rest
api
click submit
see the file is now here and now we have
to send the file to this firebase
storage
so head over to storage here and let's
enable the storage
so it's already enabled fine
so we have to import this get storage
and reference
here at the top
so we don't need get storage because we
are already having this gate strategy
here
we have to use it here the storage if we
want to use gate storage
see it's doing this here but we have
done it here in the
firebase config file
then we have to specify
which document to
which data to
save using mountain reference
reference so create it here
this should be the image name so the
image name should be called as
data.name because see
the name is here of the image so we can
just say
data.name
so that's done now we have to pass
the mountain reference to a
function so
the function is this uploads bytes
upload bytes
but if we go down here
we should see a clear view of all the
functions so we have to use
this upload for upload bytes resumable
to import it from firebase storage
here
then one more thing we need is the get
downloaded url so if our
file upload is successful we will get a
url in our console
that we can just send to database
like uh
let's say
we submitted one profile picture
and it's returning us a link
then we can send the link to database
for the avatar or for profile picture
so we have to use this upload bytes
present mobile function
to say upload task
create one instance of this it takes the
storage ref
which is not the mountain rift so pick
it straight up fine
second is the file so it's data not file
so
then we have to do just this called
uploadtask.on
so here let's do it
so upload task.on
state changed
so
it takes and call back a while so let me
just make it like this
and if you see here it's taking a
parameter called snapshot
snap
shot so in the first
callback we have to
we can get calculate the progress of how
many percentage
of the
photo has been uploaded
then using this data we can create a
progress bar
so it will be shown here
if it is an error
we can handle the error so let me just
add this here so let me console the
error so console
dot log
error
dot message wait
then if it is successful
if the file upload is done
we can just call the next function here
which is called
get download url
so you see
it's returning us a url wait
let me clear this comment
now if we refresh this okay let me just
try this
we don't have any files in the storage
so let me just choose one file so we
have chosen
if we submit here
see upload zero percent done
okay unknown error occurred
okay let me just refresh the page and
try once more
if you check here
we are passing the squid storage here
fine
all the things are great here also
so let's try this
we are using ref to specify the
reference
data dot name
okay let me pass it outside
save
now let's try to
upload one file
click submit
zero percent
okay what is the error here
okay let me see
no need occur check for payload
so let me check this
check for payload check for payload
firebase storage error
state changed
okay upload task
images
neighbors.jpg
data dot name okay
bing is back here
so we are creating the storage ref here
like this
why here we are passing this we are
passing it here the storage
so if we see
what if
construction gets storage
it's fine
we are passing the ref here
storage ref then the data in upload by
its resumable
we are using this file but here we are
using data
fine so what is the problem here
so it's not being properly uploaded
because
because why
const upload task
no task is here
dot on
fine straight changed
okay final as well snapshot progress
error
but why can't we upload a file layer
yes because the rules are not set up
here i think
so
we have to also check the rules
so
open the rules and see the rule here is
we can only upload a file only when we
are authenticated
but we are not authenticated here
so let me try once more it will work
submit
upload is 100
and see we can see the file url in the
console if we go to this link here
we should see the image that we uploaded
now
now you can use this link to send data
to firebase databases
so if you check it here also refresh the
page
wait they should be
shown here what is this what is this
in the storage
so wait a moment see the image is here
with the
name
all the things that you can use also the
location
so what if we want to upload the file in
a folder so here
in the data dot name we can specify the
folder
in a string variable
so make this as
template return lateral first
then just add
the folder let's say it's images
slash the image name
so we will send the images in the images
folder so if we try once more to send
data
so try it
choose another file any random file
then submit
it should be uploaded in an images
folder
so let me check it here refresh storage
see it's in the images and the correct
image is here
that we just
uploaded
so that's how
firebase storage works in all frameworks
for react angular view swelt javascript
next and all
all the things
so
fine
now let's see how to use the real-time
updates in the firebase firestore
so
let me show you what i mean
we are getting the data here from
getdocs function
in the created function and it's empty
here
if we had one name nishant kumar and
email
submit
it's added but it's not getting
refreshed here so to refresh the page we
have to differentiate the page manually
this click this
and only then we will get this array of
objects here from firebase firestore
so to solve this issue we have to create
one more thing called
on snapshot so import this function
and let me just comment this get box
right now
so this on snapshot listens to the
real-time updates in firebase firestore
here we have to pass the collection
reference
and one callback function
so this callback function will run every
time there is a change inside firebase
firestore
any change if we delete if we update or
if we add data
so we have to do this so it takes a
parameter
called let's make a data and just
console.log
this thing so i have already this
consoling here
so copy and just paste it
remove the comments here
let me refresh or let me format the code
here
see let's try again from the beginning
refresh the page
we have an object here coming from here
if we add one more object let's nishant
kumar too and the email something else
to submit
this new data will be here that was not
before with the get docs function
so submit
c added and we are getting listened in
real time
if we add one more
three
four four zero three
we only have three objects here
coming from here so when this data
changes here this will also change in
the front front-end app
if we delete this collection or any
field
let's see what happens the daily
document
start delete
see
here we have also refresh the page and
we only have two objects coming from
the fire store
this fire store
so that's how it works if we delete the
whole collection
we will have the empty object or empty
error there right now
so delete this
so see
the ad is now empty because it's getting
listened to in the real time
so that was how on snapshot works
to get data in real time from firebase
firestore
now let's see the firebase firestore
queries
so queries are used to filter data
based on some
field like name or age so here i have
four fields i have added which contains
name age and email so let's filter data
according to them
so we need the keyword called query from
firebase firestore
and one more thing it is called uh where
where keyword
so let me create
one const of
query so click say coinst
let's first add the age query
so it takes the query parameter
so we will filter out
the edges
which are less than
28
so i think we should get 25
21 and 20 pages
so to filter this takes the collection
reference here as first parameter
then in the second param it takes the
where
and here we define the condition so we
have to filter out based on h
to add the edge
then one comma
then we have to add the condition
whether we want it to be equal to or we
want to it to be
less than or greater than then the value
so we want the edge to be
less than 28 so here make this as
less than so if the edge is less than 98
then this will
be shown
then we have to pass this
h query to
get
the function
so in our case it's on snapshot
so on the place of collection ref pass
the edge query here
and you will see we will get the three
data here
where the edges are less than 28
20 21 and 25
if we make it more than 28 or equal to
108 we will see only one
h which is 28 here so let me just show
you
refresh
so if age is equal to 28
we will see only that data see see we
are getting only one edge
here because
only one data has the age of 28 here
so that's how edge or numeric
filter works
so let's now try to filter name query
so
for the name query we will use if the
name is equals to
this nishant kumar 4
then it will print the
data of this so if we replace the page
let's see what we have here okay
something is wrong
if name equals to this nishanth r4
okay we have to pass the query here as
well
not h query because that doesn't exist
so see
we're only getting the name because
the only one name because here the name
is shantumar4 and we are filtering it
based on that
we can also add the email or any other
field you want
and how that's how the h or any other
query works
fine here
okay make this as email
then you can see this query here
if you make it just nishant for the
gmail.com
they should be here because
this record has the email of this and
the name of this
so that's how query works in firebase
firestore
so let's learn how to host a web app or
a website to firebase hosting
so i have a react app here a blog
website that we will host
so first thing do we have to create or
we have to
install the firebase cli
so we will just do this install firebase
tools
here
let me install this
and one more thing i have to do is we
have to create a build here so npm
run build
after these two
we will be moving forward
so we have to wait for the build to
generate
and for the firebase tools to install
so let's wait
now we have the build so let's deploy it
first let's login to firebase using
firebase login ci
enter
so it will open up a window in the
chrome
sign in with this
allow this
and we are signed in with firebase
then what we have to do is we have to
initialize the project so let me just
zoom this
so we can just do firebase
in it
we want to proceed so yes
we want the hosting so
just press space to select the option
and enter
for the next step so we want the public
directory as built
because that's where the build is enter
so okay we don't need this automatic
build
okay wait something wrong so let me do
it once more
let me clear it first
we have to initialize it using this
so yes
we want the hosting
enter
build is the public folder
we want the
single page app yes
you want you don't want the automatic
builds no
you don't want to override this no
that's all
let's just use the command called
firebase
deploy to deploy this
so the step is to generate a build first
then to login
then to initialize
then to deploy
so we have different commands for
generating the build for angular for
react and for any other framework like
next
so that's how we do it here
so see
it's getting or giving us a website link
here so let's open it and see
we should see the website here
so this is the website that we just
hosted
in this link
and that's how firebase hosting works
now let's look into the firebase
security rules
so if you open firebase rules here
the rules are now set to public it means
anyone can write data or read them
so
even if we are not authenticated in
firebase using login and password
we can draw data or read them so let's
try this currently we are not logged in
because we are getting this message of
not logged in
coming from this on our state changed
that tells us that
if we are logged in
we will see an alert
of logged in but if we are not we will
see the elect of not logged in
in my previous video
i have shown this how to use the on or
state changed
or not state changed yes
so we can also read data open the
console
see it's empty right now because the
data is empty here
so let me now add one data without
signing in
we are not signed in
not logged in
add the email at the name the email and
some age
click add here
see we are seeing the islet of data
added and if we check here
it will be added here it will be having
one
document of h25
email and the name that we just added
here
and we can read them also open the
console
see it's coming here in the console
so now let's change the rules to
authenticated
it means we will write data only if we
are authenticated
so let me do it here
so remove this state right now
okay just do if
allow right only if
if
the request
dot auth is not equal to empty
so we can make it null here
so it means
it will allow us to read data or write
it i mean
when we are logged in when the
request.auth is not null
if it is not null there should be some
data inside the request.org
the data we get from the authentication
when we sign up or sign in
so second thing to write here is allow
read in any case
so
write is authenticated proof
authentication proof but not this read
so publish this rule
and open data tab
so like now let's try data without
signing it we are not logged in
and the name the email and the age click
add
see we are getting this message called
messing out insufficient permissions
but we can read data so open the console
we are getting the data ifc
the h25 and the blah blah message or the
fields here we are writing it here so
now let's make the role of rig to be
authenticated profile as well
so
do it here like this
and you will see
we will still get that error that we got
in the right open right operation
so save this or publish this
open the console you will see the
message of
permission is not sufficient so defeat
the page
not logged in
see
error in the snapshot listener firebase
error
missing or insufficient permissions so
it means
we don't have permissions to read data
because
we are not logged in
so now let's try to login
add the email
and the password
log in here
you'll see now we're logged in
and if we refresh the page
so see we should see the data here
because it's allowing us to read
after authentication
now now let's add data
after authentication
the email and the age
so click add here
see data added here
so that how authentication works i mean
that's how
the rule works in firebase firestore
tools
authentication and all
one more thing there is there is to
allow the
users to
uh read write in no cases so it means
even we are logged in or
we are in the authenticated tab
it should allow us to not write data
so we will just add if false here
and here as well okay just make it only
in the right permission
this allow us to
this will allow us to write data in no
cases even if
we are authenticated so refresh page
when logged in let's add data
the age
click add
see
we don't have the permission to see the
data i mean to write data
so that's how firebase fires rule works
now let's handle the firebase real-time
auth updates
so i mean
when we login our app should send data
to firebase that we're logged in
if we log out our app should send data
to firebase that we're logged out
so
if here i have an email one and one
password field login button and logged
button
i have added one email here of my email
so let me just create this on off state
chat function
that relation to us on state changed in
real time so just make it like this here
and create one use effect hook
use effect
simple as that
make it an empty string here i mean t
array
so just call the function here
so i mean when we are logged in it takes
an auth parameter
and second thing it takes is an callback
function
callback function returns some data to
us so we can say
data
and control it here
data
if i check this console here
let's see what we have initially
so we are getting the data here because
now we are logged in so let me start
from the beginning log out
fine
so
sorry now we're logged out
here
so let me enter the email and password
email is this and the password is
something
okay fine
so if i click login with the email and
password this function or not state
changed it is sending data to firebase
that we are logged in
if we click log out
this will send data to firebase that we
are logged out
and it's persisting
even if we refresh the page it will
still exist
so unless we log out or log in the state
will not change
so if i log in
click the button here
we will get all the data here see
even if we refresh the page it will be
still getting the data we will still
hitting the data here
but if we click log out
there should be null
it means now we are logged out
so let me just refresh the page and you
will still see the null because
we have not logged in we are logged out
let me give you one more thing here
so create check if data exists
or if it's not null
or if we are logged in
we will show an alert here
every time it runs that we are
logged
in
but else if
or just
else okay just make it else
we will see an alert that we are logged
out
or not
log in
save this and now let's try this
to see
we are reading this message called
logged logged in
so refresh the page still the same
because we have not logged in
if we enter the email and the password
we should see
that we are logged in now okay then if
we refresh
we are logged in because
firebase has set the state
of past state to logged in
if we log out the state will change to
logged out
so that was all about on a state change
in firebase which listens to our
real-time updates in auth
so create a file called index.js here
and one
sorry index.js yes and one for html so
index
dot html
so they are running here
so let's add the
emit code here
and make this as firebase
js
so first in this first video we will
just
learn how to
authenticate and
use the current operations for
javascript for vanilla js i mean
so let's link the script tag here
script
script src
so it's index.js
and let me format this fine
so we will write everything inside the
body
and put the script tag after the body
because it should load after here
so let's start by creating a firebase
app here so go to console here
add a project
let's make it
firebase
front end
continue
create project here
it's creating so
let's run the file layer with live
server
so it's running here but we can't see
because we don't have anything
so let me make a div and let's make four
in
puts or first let's make the two inputs
for authentication so we will have input
of email
placeholder of email
wait
sorry
email
and make this
then second one should have
the
place order of password
password save and we have email and
password
let's give them a styling so
create one css file as well here so this
should be index
dot css
simple
and link the css here
so we can just say
link css
and
index.css
save
so give this name a class name of our
class of you know class name
let's say
main
and here in the css we will just say
mean
display of flex
hide something 100 viewers
and
justify content center
align items
like a line
item center so they are now in the
center
positions
so we need to make them
row wise so we can also to
do
flex direction of row
or i think it should be column yes that
column wise not row voice
so we have now two input fields email
and password let's add some label
label email
and put them in a div
so this
email and password sorry this email
level and the email input field are now
one combination so do it again for the
second
here
for the input of password
and at the level
this should be password
tip and now we have these two
okay
or what we can do is just rename the
main to body
fine it's now fine
so we have email and password let's give
them
the level some styling
or leave it it's fine
we are not focusing on the styles
so we need a button here so make a
button make it a
hey
submit
here
and
give the button a class name of
submit button or btn
and in the css let's add the class name
here
it should be
position of absolute
then left fifty percent
top fifty percent
and
save it then we also have to add a
little bit more margin at the top
so margin top 30 pixels or 40
50
fine we have now email and password to
submit button
so now let's get the data from these
inputs so make this as id
add id
value and make it as email and this
should be password
ids password
also let's add the name of input fields
this should be email
and
they should be password so name is
password
so now let's format them properly
give them a little indentation or
whatever it is
and then just
wait
okay fine it's fine
so
we have now the email and password
fields now let's get data from them
so to get data just open index.js file
and create a function so const
register
which will be
an error function
here let's get data from this input
field first is email
so let me give the type of the input so
this should be email here
and here there should be password
type of password
then let's
add the inputs here so const
const email equals to
uh what should we call it
document.getelementbyid
the email id
and dot value
to get its value
then we have to just use password
equals to document.getelementbyid
and the password
its value
if we control these values we should be
able to see them
but first let's bind this function to
this button here
the submit button
on click
wait
on click
register
and now if you try to console them
console dot
log
email and password
let's see what we get so open the
console inspect element
and enter the email
my and some password
submit see we are now getting the email
and the password in the console
so we remove this console log
let's create the firebase app click the
web here
and give the name firebase
end
and here i have a guide on how to add
firebase
to the
javascript library
so use the script tag here
so we don't need all this right now so
just open this
documentation i will leave the link in
the comments or in the description
copy this three cdn tags ctn links i
mean
and paste it after
sorry paste it before the index.js
so we have this three
what is it three links or script tags
first is for auth and this is for
firebase
pirate store
so and the third is for app
so we have to just
use this cons firebase initializer in
our index
dot js so save it here
and open index.js
then we can just initialize it at the
top
then
we have to add our config here
all this data
this data
so copy these things
i api key all domain and all and add it
here
okay then we have to initialize our
database firestore database and auth so
let's do it
do it here
and
now we can just use this auth
to
sign up so we can just say auth
dot sign sorry we have to use create
user with
email
and
password so
mind the spelling
and
it's a camel case letter
user is use capital vw's capital a is
capital null
and we have to pass this email password
inside this as params
email and password
then it's a promise so we can have a
then block
it's as a response to us
and we can say response
dot
user in the console is res dot
user
let's also add a cache block if it fails
so catch
so this should be
why should we call this it should take
an error here
error
and we can say console.log
error
dot message
and one more for the code so let's add
the code here
error.code
so let's try this now but first thing to
do is continue to console here
open the auth tab in the
side menu
authentication tab
click get started here
then activate email and password sign-in
method
save it
and we are done here so click users you
see we don't have any users here so
let's add one
enter the email but first open the
console
enter the email and some password
click submit
see we are getting this all the data
here
with auth display name email and
everything else
so we can use the display name it's null
email is my name and everything else
here
if we refresh this data in the firebase
console authentications we will see our
email here you see
our email has been registered now
if we try to create the one more data
if sorry if you try to create
the
account with same email we will fail
submit it here
see we are getting this message called
auth or email already news so we can add
alert here
alert
which says
error dot
message
so just add it here
and
use same email and password
see the email is already in use by
another account
so this is sign up so create one more
function for login so const
log in
we will use same params i mean we will
use the same data here same input fields
and all
so in the login we need one more button
so create one button here
that will point to
sign in
we can make this as law we can make this
as
sign up to
yes but they are overlapped
so what we can do is
we are doing submit button here okay
make this as
login button
and
here just add a new styling of login
button
make the same style here
but it will be the same so make the left
to 60 percent
and this to be 40
fine don't mind the design we're just
using the functionality there
so in the index.js we are using this
register so make it as login
for sign in method
and here
let's add the
email password here like this
and we can just say auth
dot sign in
with
email
and
password i think the spelling is right
it also takes two parameters email
and
password
so all the things here will be the same
so just copy this then catch block and
paste it
let's add an alert here as well
okay elect will not work here fine so
now let's try to log in
so enter the email and password
and click sign in but open the console
first
to jk if it works or not sign in
see
we are getting all the data here which
says auth display name email and email
verified
and all the data
what if we entered the wrong email that
has not been registered yet we will get
an error
in the alert so sign in
see
we are getting this there is no user
according to this identifier
the user may not user may have been
deleted and what not
so it's working and if we enter the
right email but the wrong password you
will get the password error sign in
see the password is invalid or the user
doesn't know does not have password
fine
so it's working fine the email and sign
up
now let's
see how to use the
save data to firebase firestore
so pin this firestore database here
oh my good
chocolates
so create database
and
start in test mode here because we are
testing it
so it's all the things they are fine
so it's initializing and provisioning
cloud fire store
meanwhile we can create a function here
so it will say const
save data for same function
we will use this method to save data
so
let's comment all this code here because
we have already seen how this works
so comment all this input
no don't comment it we will reuse it
so create one more button here
so it should be known as
save data
we can comment these buttons here
because we don't need them anymore right
now
so save data so we will just save the
email and password in the fire extra
database
that will that will work
fine so we have saved data here and
add this function to this button so on
click
on click this function of save data
so we need the user an email we need the
email and password i mean
so add it here and it will work
if we click save button here this should
get the email password in our
function here
so to add data we can just do this
simple thing so if we check the
documentation here
it's listed here i will leave the link
in the description
so we have to add the collection name
first so db.collection
so collection should be the user's
collection
then we will use an add keyword
to add data in the collection so first
thing is our email add the email as
email
then we have a password
to add password as password
then if it's successful we can just use
our then block
so it takes a doc ref
and we can just console
dot log
this data
so let me use this data copy this and
just replace the console log here and if
it fails we will use cache block
okay so now let's try this our database
is empty you see
here
let's add one email and some password
so if you open the console
and save data
we will get the message called document
written with id this id
if we check firebase firestore and
refresh this once
we should get the data here with that
same id that we saw here
see it's same and the email and password
is restarted in the collection
so for example this is an
array
this one is an object and in this object
we have the email and password fields
let's add one more
let's change some
data and save
see that another one is here and it
should be here as well
see
so our ad doc is functioning properly
now now let's
see how to read data
from firestore
so to read data let's add a function
here as well so cons
read data
and just add the function here wait
in the
index.html so when the button here
button this should be read wait a sec
read data
just say
on the on click event on click
there should be red data here say when
we have a button called redata
that will correspond to this function
call
so to read data
it's very very very simple so we have to
just say db
dot collection
and in the collection let's pass the
collection name which is called
users
the collection name is users here
and you see here
we will be using a get keyword here to
get the data
so we can use get
and it will send us some data back so we
can just say
dot then
to see in the console the upcoming data
we can make it as document
or let's make it simply data
then we will just say
console.log
data
so if you open the console now
click this red data button
gate is not defined wait a second let me
see what's the problem
the gate is not defined
okay okay okay if we just copy this and
let me just replace all these things
here wait wait so gate is not defined
because we have to use a dot here
before this get
that's why
so save it and check again
ray data
we are hitting this data here but
it's not clear to us what is this
so let me just
filter it out so data docs we can
do we have to get the documents inside
so we will use docs
red data again
so we're getting this array here
and inside this array we have to find
our data
so we'll map these arrays so we will say
map
it will send us an item
as
callback
then we will just say console or we will
just say
return
the item
so we will return the item.data
so this item have a data
as a retirement so if we save and check
again
we should get these two array
objects
for the both fields here for both
objects
but the thing is we're not getting the
id so we should get the id by
just adding id and this should be
item dot id
so create click recreate again
they should have an id here see this
unique id for both
documents
so this is how we retain firebase
firestore
now in the third thing let's see how to
update data
so just say const one more function
called update data
equals to
this add a function
and we will do the collection name here
so we will add the collection name
then we have to specify the collection
id
so we have to add it here this one and
this one
so we can just say dock
keyword
and we have to pass the id here
so just pass the id this one
and then we have to update it so we can
say
update and we have to add the update
date data to update first
so let's first make the email to be
something else to make it
uh
sheesh
is a
good boy one
two three
i read the red gmail
dot com
so
the password should be same so if you
make the password to
okay let's make this as one two three
four five six
fine
so we will update the
which field we will update the first
field
this nishanth has four four zero one
enter gmail.com
so we need to pass this function to a
button
so we can create one button here
it's just for showing you
update one
field and just pause the button here of
one click
on click
this
wait this function
update data
save it
so we have to get a promise based
response so just
use dot then
and
we will just say
alert
data
save it and let's check it now
if you click update one field
this nishant as 4401 should be this
email that we wrote here in the email
click update one field
okay it's not defined so i guess you
have to use it in an string like this so
now let's try again
update one field
see updated here
and if we check here
they see this email is now aashish
is a good buy and blah blah blah
so we can change it again to one two
three two one two three four
and if we save it
update again
so it's updated
and here also
one two three now one two three four
so it's done now let's delete this field
so make this as delete
data and one more button here
to delete this field
so make this as this function called
daily data
paste it and save the file here
and here also
but let's delete this field called
nishan there's
the gmail.com and the password one two
six
so we will just say delete so it will
say dock here it's fine
we will just use this delete
so delete
delete
and
we will save it and let's try this now
so if we click this we change the name
to delete one field
and click this
it's updated but this should be deleted
yes but
it's not here anymore this
field that we deleted right now
okay we deleted the wrong field
fine doesn't matter
so
we have deleted this field of this id
but it's not here anymore so let me just
show you again one more so make this as
where
here there should be data deleted
so let me add one one field here so add
email
and some
password
save data
saved here and it should be here
so we have two fields
this and this
we can read them if you click this
red data
we are getting two fields here
we can update the one field so
we are using this id to update so let me
use this id
so if you read it again and copy the id
here
so let me get this id of
six ca whatever and we will update this
field of
nissan as four for zero there gmail.com
so save the index.js file
and they should be updated
wait not this this should be updated
if we click update this
name should be asish is a good
boy
one two three four at the gmail.com so
let's try it update one field
and you will get this message called
data updated in the alert
and this should be c ashish one two
three
sorry ashish is a good boy one two three
four
and if we delete the field here so
this field will be deleted
but the thing is we don't have the id of
this field
so it's not here if we click delete we
should get an error so we can just say
dot catch
so it take it takes a parameter called
error so we can just say console
dot log error
if we now
delete this field here we should get the
error of
that deleted weight okay this side is
not present
but how can i delete i think
something is wrong here
doesn't matter so
let's replace the id with this sb as wb
and whatever so rate data and just copy
the ide this one
and place it here
in one code not two quotes
okay when we will delete this field
called second one nishan there's 440.3
gmail.com password126 and the ids
swb qtmg
so click delete one field
delete it
and they shouldn't be here see we only
have one field
if we delete this one also we have to
pass the id here
like this
so relate this field as well
and if we read it we will have empty
object here
empty array i mean
and nothing here
so our four operations are now working
which are create rate update and delete
as well as the registered and login
methods
so we have done auth and we have done
database files database i mean
so next up is angular
so first of all let's create one angular
project
make sure that you have installed the
angular cli using this command
and to create a new app we will use the
command called ng new
i am name my app
so paste it here and let's change the
app name to but fit let's first
change the directory to angular here
then we will
use this command this should be
angular
angular
fire base save it
and it will create a project in the
angular folder
it will take some time
so even the routing yes
we want css
so it's installing all these things here
so let's wait for it to install
and the angular app has now been created
so now let's change the folder
just do
cd
what is it
angular firebase so angular and
angular
a hyphen fire
base enter
now we are in that folder here
so it has so many files here that i am
not going to explain to you
what are these
but
we have to install one package here
called angular file this is the
official
package
for angular so you see
it's asking us this thing so you can say
yes or no it doesn't matter
so it will do some interesting things
here
so yes we want to proceed
it's installing the package
see it's written here that the official
angular library for firebase
and
they are here
i will show you how to use this all
things
so it's installing the packages
we must wait for it
and now it's asking a few things here so
we want authentication here
authentication so select
we don't need deployment okay let's just
select authentication
we don't need deployment to leave it for
now we need fire store
okay we need authentication and fire
extrude
then enter
it will automatically configure the
project for this authentication and
firebase firestart i mean
so enter your email account
yes this is my email account
see it's asking the project name so all
the project from firebase
has been listed here so let me choose
the firebase front-end project here
this project here
from the flyer cloud
so
yes we need this app
what would you like to call your new app
so make it wait a sec
we did something wrong we have to start
again
because
we didn't need a new app we had already
an app here that we can use
so that's a mistake i did from foreign
for a very long time
after a long time i mean
so we don't need deployment this
authentication and firestore enter
yes
email is this
let's choose the project name firebase
front end
so we need this so just use arrow keys
to navigate we don't need to create a
new app
if you don't have any app here in
firestore you can create it
so it's downloading configuration data
and it's done
and if we check our
what is it environment
environment where is it
in src environments folder
environment ots
we will see
our storage
environments see in this we have project
id all these things
that is coming from this project
overview so let me show you
if we scroll down to this easy all these
things are now here automatically so
it's a relief in the both production and
development type script environment file
so now what we have to do is start our
app so we can just say ng server
enter
so let me go to firestore database sorry
let's go to authentication first because
first of all we will handle
authentication
so
it's starting let's wait for up the app
to start it will take some time maybe
one day or two days
then i will come back
so our project has now been compiled so
let's open it on the local host 4200
okay
so open it here localhost four to zero
zero
let's bring it and the front
so close the app module.ts
let's check app.module.htm
app.component.html so we also don't need
this terminal so close the panel
remove
so we can remove it or leave it so let's
remove it all the html data here
and in the ts
you will see we are getting import all
the
uh things are being imported
automatically like environment
get fire stored get us and all that we
just that we chose before
so let me just format this and close
this
open abroad component
dot ts
so these are the this is the component
for this html so we write html layer and
here we write the logic
the
logic yes
so let's get data first or okay so let's
handle authentication first
so we need to input fields so let's make
it an input of
input of placeholder this should be
email
and make it auto close
see we have the email field here then
make one for password
input placeholder
password
save them we have input and password
email and password fields
and what we can do is we can just copy
the
previous input from
this page so just copy this
div
and place in the html file like this
so remove the buttons command buttons
and
let's just
add the styling from index.css so copy
all this styling
and place into this app.com.css
and save
and save this as well
now they are here but they are not in
the center
so what we can do is
we don't okay we don't we can't use body
here
so copy these things and
cut it and paste it in the
okay wait let's do thing let's do this
so just copy main class name
and replace body
and
it will be in the center like this
so let's give them a margin little bit
so what we can do
in this input of what is the class name
we don't have class name here
so give them a class name of
input
fields and copy the input class name
fields
and add it here
so let's give them a little bit margin
before between them
so margin
10 pixels
fine we have some margin between them
okay what we can do we don't need the
input label so remove them
it's
fine without them so let me just now
give this inputs a class name
because it's maybe hard for you to see
the input fields here
but if it's if it does not it's then
good
so class
input
field
so don't confuse between these fields
and this field
this is one field and this is single
plural fields
singular and plural
i mean singular and plural
copy the input fields and here we can
just do
a little bit styling so width should be
40 sorry which should be hundred let's
make it 100
height should be
40 px
okay
why is this not working
okay we need one dot also here
fine so if we refresh okay it's too
technically so make this 20 a height and
300 input
so these are this now look fine i think
now we need a button
so we can just make a button here
button
so this should be wait a second who is
this novel is this
the button should be
let's say sign a
and one more for sign up
sign up
see we have two buttons
give them a class also
button or we can just do here
submit button we already have so we
don't need to use this we can remove
these buttons
we will just say button
and
width
30px 30 will be small i think not 30
let's make it 100
100
and height should be
20
20 ps
fine
also margin a little bit 10 pixels
so our sign up button and the sign in
button is now created
make the height to 40
okay this looks fine also
one more thing to its cursor is pointer
here so make it
so we have sign in button and signup
button
now we need to get data from these two
fields so let's do that
so i have wrapped the whole code in a
form tag and i'm using this login form
as ng form
then a function called handler register
which is sending the login form value
here we have ng model in the both fields
and we can collect our value
when we click sign up or sign in
so now what we have to do is we have to
do what we have to import a few things
so first
import
what do we have to import from
firebase
wait not firebase
we have to use angularfire then auth
and from here let's import a few things
first is
auth second is create user with email
and password
and third one is
sign in sign in with email and password
these three things
so let me break this down nine ports
here like this
and
we have to make a constructor here so
constructor
and we have to create
one auth type here so auth will be
of auth type this like this
so remove console from the values
here
and it's here so what we have to do is
we have to just do
this thing which is called
create user with email and password then
we have to pass
this auth
then the email so email is our value dot
email
and third thing is that value dot
password
password and it will work
wait
value dot password
why i cannot type properly
fine
but
we have to use there this auth not
direct auth
and what is the error
it does not
it does not exist on the app component
so make this as public
i can doing
public now it is fine here
we can make it private but public is
fine
so now we can sign up and it will return
an update it will return some data so we
will just catch it so we will just say
response
and the type here will be any
and we will just say
console.log or just say
alert
response okay okay
so we have to console it here not just
showing the alerts the console.log
response.user
but if it fails we will just catch it
so catch error we will show in the
console
sorry we showed the alert
so alert this should be error dot
message
then just save it
and
let's sign up now
in the firebase we have one email which
is nishan that's 440.gmail.com
so we can
sign up or sign in so let's first sign
up because it is create user
enter the password
sign up here
see auth email already news we are
getting this error here
and if we sign in
we will the same because the both are
the same so remove sign in button
but if you sign up with different email
it will work so let me see
let me show you open the console clear
it and change the email a little bit and
the password
sign up
we are getting all the data here you see
and in this one it will be updated in
the fire store com firebase
authentication c
so now let's add the login so just
duplicate the form or
just select the form here comment out
this handle register function
create one more function called handle
login
just like this so it will accept the
value
and i will just
pass the function here
not handle register
so fail to compile because we have to
save this
vs code
and we will just use this second
property called sign in with email and
password so it will take the same things
first is the auth so just copy this auth
value out email and password
and we are done
let's also copy this then and catch
block
put it before this
after this sorry not before
format this now let's try to login
what is the error
okay we did something wrong
so i guess we are using one extras
curly braces now it will work fine
so enter the email and password
so email is nishant s some password
sign up okay let's make this button a
sign in
now
so click sign in enter the email and
password
if you open the console it should work
because
we have the correct email and password
see it's returning us this data
all the data that we get from firebase
if we enter the wrong email which
doesn't have which which is not a
present in the authentications you will
get an error
in the alert see auth or user not found
but if we enter the wrong
password but the right email we will
still get an error
auth wrong password
see it's now working
so our authentication is done so now
let's see add document in the fire store
database so we need few changes make
this as add data
add data
let's say the function name
this should be add data
and remove all these things from here
and also
this previous sign and method
so we don't need this public auth and
auth instance and remove this import
from fireauth
then
we have to add this data to this
function
so if we enter them if we enter some
name and password they should be here in
the console if we check it
now let's import
a thing here so import
so it will be from
angular fire angler
slash fire and the thing to import is
let me break it down first
the first thing to import is
what do we input add doc
second is firebase
okay we have to also use
angular fire slash firebase
firebase spotify store not firebase
then add dock is done we have to import
uh
firebase
for the fire not firebase firestore to
initialize for our firestore
then collections give out to specify the
collections here
so add these three things first
then in the constructor
we have to add the instance of firestore
so we can say public
fire store
and fire store like this save
so you see we don't have we only have
one account here one document
so let's add one more
so to add we i just use the collections
first so
cons
db instance
to select our database so we can have
multiple collections here
so let's select the connection we have
to add data inside
so we can just do
we added collect
we have added collection here collection
like this
and then just pass this fire store
instance so this
dot fire store
second thing it takes is the collection
name so it's users
and we are done here
then we have to pass this table instance
in add doc function with the data we
have to add
so pass table instance and the values so
values like this
value we have single value fine
so we can use then block if it success
if it is successful
we will just
say alert
data print
but if it fails we will just say dot
catch block
wait
some error it takes as param
and we can throw an alert
which will say error
dot
message
now let's try this
oh
what is this why are you reading this
never translate this side so let's add
one email
and some
password for there to send one two three
four five six add data
data send and let's check here
see we have another data here that says
the email and password
we can add more fields so let's add
more fields
so make this as name
input name name placeholder as name
id
as name we don't need id here but it's
fine
type will be text
and that's fine we have three fields now
so if we send it
we will have our third field in the
document here so let's try this
all right the second thing no we're not
missing anything
let's add the name the email
then the password
add data sent and it will be here with
the third
new input field which is name
see we have all these three things here
so that's how we add data
in firestore using angular
now let's read the documents from the
fire store so import
get docs function
let's create a collection here
in the constructor
and what we can do is we can create one
more function here so
we will call
get doc or get data
like this
we can just create a collection here and
then we will just pass the collection
to this get docs function
so the connection is db instance
so pass this here and it will return
some data so call then block
and we'll send us the response and we
will just
do
con we will just do
console dot
log
response dot data
dot data dot dot
dot
not
dot map it will take an item again
and then we can just return
the
item
like this with the id of the item so
make the ideas
uh item dot id
what is the problem here
it is not callable
so what we are doing wrong here
okay we have to you we are using return
fine
so what we can do we just open the
javascript file here in the js
and then just copy this block
of then data
and replace it it will be the same but
okay we have to get the data here we can
just say item.data
fine
if we open the console but we have to
call the function here
in the
constructor we will use this keyword for
that reference
and if we say well let's check the
console
refresh we are getting the three arrays
here you see
password
with the password email and the name if
it has a name
so now we can store it in a variable so
let's make a variable here
so
public
public
data
it will be an array
so make any
fine
and just initialize it like this
save
and if we just store this data here it
will work so we can just do data or
this.data
equals to
this
response within spread operator to
spread it inside this data
and it's getting stored in the data
variable so we have to just
open or just copy this public data and
here
let's add in the
after the form
so we can comment this all the things
here and just
do
an evil tag
inside an ally list tag
let's look through the array so we will
just do
mg4
and g4 then it takes a item so let's say
let
item
of this array of data then we can just
do
item okay two curly brackets i think
we can just do item dot name save
we are writing the name because we only
have one name here so we make it this is
email
or
let's add
like this so first will be the email
third will be the
password
save
and we will get our email
the password and if we have a name we
will get that too
so
we are saying all this let me zoom it in
and you will see also
the email
the password and the name for the
respective lists
so redlock is also done
now let's update the data
so we need a button here first
to add a button
and this will be called
update
save it
and
let's create or let's import two things
here which will be called dock and
update talk
doc will be used to
specify which document to update
but
an update doc will be used to
update the document that we chose
using this doc so create a function
const
update data
okay not paused file
that's an error
update data
just update data it will take a id of
thing
type string
fine
then we have to add the button
a function to this button so on click
not on click just a click
and just make the update data function
and the id will be passed here so item
dot id we have to receive it here we are
saving it so save the file
if we control the id we should get the
id of that field we are clicking on
id
open the console
let's try this click update for this
first field
it's getting here this one and this one
here we are getting the id
and we will not use dynamic imports i
mean we will not click the button
and its value will populate it in a for
we will just update it statically
using the static data that we want
so what we can do here is
we can
specify which document to update first
so make const
data to
update equals to we will use doc keyword
here
it will take three parameters
the two of them is called this firestore
instance and
the collection name third one will be
the id
select which document to update
then we will just use update doc
function and we will pass two things
here
data to update and the data we want to
update so let's add the name here
so
let's add the name of
ashish
fine
save this
if it is successful we will throw then
block here and we can just do
alert
data
updated
and if it fails we will just catch it
and say error
alert
couldn't or just throw the error dot
message here
fine
save
now let's update any field so here we
don't have the name of ashish
so it will be added if you click update
here
and one more thing we do we can do is we
can just call this getdata function
after we are updating
because then it will automatically
replace the page and get all the data so
make this as
this would get data to call the function
here
so now like click the update of first
here click it
update it
and see the assist name is popped up
here if you change it to something else
let's say
put there and click another one let's
see this last one
this should be here the name of the
third field
updated and it's here
if we click the previous one which has
already the name nishant
it will be here that was our name
not nishant
so we can change it like this
okay the fourth one we will delete
so we also need one more button here so
let's add it
it will be simple as well to delete
the function name will be delete
data
so just save the file and
create a function here
delete data
okay
then
we have to add the collection sorry
after document which document to update
so make this as document data or delete
simple
we have to import the delete dock as
well here so delete
dock
so just add it here
so we can do
delete dock and pass this
here
simple
and the rest will be then in clash block
the usual things let's also get the id
here
the id of string
because we also need the id
and add it in the params
save and
we will say delete function button here
if we click delete here
make this as data deleted first
if we delete here this should be related
deleted and it will be disappeared
if we click delete for the this one okay
let me just change the few things
make this update here
but first let me change it to nishant
we can change other fields as well so if
we change the email here
in update
it will be updated so let's say nishant
one two three at the rate gmail.com
so here in this scenario we are writing
two fields
so if we change the first
the name and email will be changed here
click update
updated
and the email is now
nishanth123.gmail.com
and the password is the still this
password is same but the name has been
changed
so let's delete this nashanth field
deleted
and it's not here anymore we only have
one field
and it's being updated dynamically
so our four operations are now done
which is called credit operations as
well as create
sort as well as sign up and sign in with
email account and password
so that was all about angular
and how to handle firebase
authentication and clear operations in
angular
now let's handle the firebase
authentication and cloud operations in
react
so into that folder of react we will
create our application we will just type
nbx
wait let me just
zoom the terminal npx create
react app and the app name so make it
firebase
react
let me just see in angular we have
angular firebase
so let's make it react firebase
and
the name should be in small letters
this should this
you should keep in mind
so let's wait for it to finish
it's creating a new app in the folder of
react
so our react app has now been created
and it started here
so we need to do one more thing here so
just open a terminal and just to npm
install
firebase we have to install this package
so install it
and wait for it to finish
then we have to create here two input
fields so let's create them
so remove this logo svg from there
so to create two input fields we will
just say input
and placeholder
as
let me make this as email
and
name of email also
and
the type of email as well
so type this type of email
email
repeat it once more for the password
make this as
password
name as password and this one is
password as well
type
save it and we can say to input name and
pass email and password
so remove the class name app and replace
it with the
app header
save and let's remove the unnecessary
class name like this applogo media
queries
and app link and the keyframes here at
the bottom
remove the background color here
fine now give this input to class names
or one class names i mean for both of
them
so let me just
format this
so this should be
what should we call this input
class name of
input
fields
so here should we should give the input
field some margin
10 pixels so we have some margin here
let's add a button at the bottom
button to submit the form so make this
as let's first sign up because
we will use signup methods first
so we need here two functions in the
android js so create them
the const
handle input
inputs so it will handle the both inputs
at the same time
one more function to submit to handle
submit equals to
this
function
so the handle input
we will target it on this input space
so on change
it will take a parameter called event
and we will just send the event to this
function using
argument and props but argument in
params not props and same here
so
and in the handle summit button we will
just map it here in the button
on click
handle submit so let's
create one state here first import the
user from react
use state
from
react
and we will just
do a state let's create one state
so const
data
set
data
equals to use date it will be an object
and it contains it will contain two
properties
so first will be the email
and it will be empty initially then the
password also empty
initially
then here we will have to get the input
so say event
we will receive it here and let's create
a new let variable so let
uh input
equals to
so we will do it like this in the inputs
we will just
do
event dot target
dot name
and if the name matches we will store
the value in the name so if it is email
coming from this name of
email and if it is password coming from
this name password
if they are matching we will just store
them inside their respective states
object states so email email password
password
so here we will just say event
the target dot
value
so in this input we are setting it
inputs
then we have to just
store this data in set data
to set data we can just say
input using
three dots to spread them
inputs
and
we have also to store the previous data
but let me show you what i mean so if we
console this so console.log
this data and if we enter the ml and
password here
it won't work perfectly so let me show
you open the console
enter the email and some password
sign up
see we are only getting the password not
the email that's by that's because we
are setting only the
field of inputs and let's say we entered
the first we entered the email first
then the password
so this password is overriding the email
and that's why we are saying only the
password
so to fix that we have to just
pass the data as well this data
so it will contain the
current data and the previous data so
save and now let's check
refresh and just entered email and
password
sign up okay we are writing this as
empty
i guess i have to pass it before inputs
so first tell you the data then the
input
now let's check
email and the password
yes now we see we are getting this email
and the password now we can use this in
the fire store authentication
so let's add authentication
authentication authentication to import
let's import the two things from that
oh yes so we need the app
and the
database so first let's create them
so in the source folder create a file
called
firebase config.js
and in the file we have to just
import the firestore configuration for
this project
so copy these things here and add it
here
so we have to export the construct
and we need one more thing from the fire
store database
get fire store which is called so get
fired store
from
firebase slash firestore
so i think the import name is correct
get fired story okay fire so it is a
single line
i mean single word
so
we have to initialize the
fire code as well so export
export
const let's make it
okay just database
equals to
get fired stored and just pass the app
credentials inside here this app
now it will work so now let's import
these two ipad database in the app.js
main file
import app
and database from
one step back firebase config file fine
so we're done here
but we have to get authentications
things also to open authentications tab
first
we have two emails so let's add one more
from the react app
so let's make this as import empty from
let's add the import first
firebase auth
this one
and in this
curly brackets we have to import
first is the get auth
second is the sign in with
email and password for the login and
create user with the email password
for
create account
creating account here
so these three we need
we need to create one instance for the
auth so const or equal to get auth
and in the
submit function handle submit we have to
just
call this function called
create user with email and password we
will pass this auth here
auth instance
then the email and password
so we can just pass
so what
the state name data
dot email
comma data
dot password so it takes three
paragraphs you already know from my
previous videos for other frameworks
it takes auth data email and data
password
i mean email and password
then we have to use a then block to make
it a successful
message so response
and
we will just say console
dot log
response
else if it okay it spawns the data sorry
user not data
and if it fails we can just say catch
error
and this should be
alert
error dot
message
so if we save and now let's try to add
some input
if we sign up we will get an error
because we already have this email
present in the authentication
we can't create it duplicately
sign up
you see we are writing this email or
already news
but if we use the wrong or different
email let's say
4403 and click sign up
it will be successful
so we are reading all this data here and
here if we refresh the authentications
tab it will be here in the users
see this one
so it's done
so now let's add the sign in bangtan so
add this says
or make the signup sign in
and here just replace this
function of create user with email
password with this sign in with email
password so add it here
and if we now try this
it should work we will get the same data
here
see we are getting this data because now
we are not creating the account we are
signing in
if we use the wrong email that is not in
the users tab here we will get error so
try it
see auth user not found
but if we use the wrong password as well
we will get the password error so make
this something else
that is not present in the store this
authentication
sign in
wrong password
so this is how we
handle signup and sign in method
so
one thing to show you before this is
so we can store this token inside our
social storage
and
we can use it for our authentication
there are other methods there are other
methods as well you can use them as well
so these are done
so now let's see how to
send data to firebase firestore
so we need a few things here as well so
first will be
a collection to create a collection or
to get the collection
and add doc so first let me just import
from firebase slash
fire store
this
so we are importing collection and add
doc so collection may be used to specify
a collection and add lock will add data
inside the collection
so let me remove this
because we will just send data from here
so we can just make this button off
sign in with send or add data
we need to add one more field here
called name so let me add it here
so make the placeholder as name
name as name
type as text fine we are done and here
one more
object property called name
empty initially
and it's done
so now we can install our name here as
well
so what we can do is
in the handle commit function
we have to use
first let's create a collection so if we
open
the
firestore database
we will see our collection name here
so it's called users
so we need to add the connection name so
we can do it like this const
let's say database
which database to edit
users to edit
and then we have to
pass
this
uh what is it this database where is it
this database here
okay wait
first will be database then the users
so now
save them it takes two params we will
use okay
let's make it db instance
instance
because we have two databases now
so we will use
add doc
then we will pass the db instance and
then the data
so our data is
this data so simply pass it like this
and it's done so if it is successful we
will then
call then block
and here we will just show an alert that
says that
data sent
or else if it fails we will catch the
error using catch block
which will show us an error so alert
error
dot message
save and now let's try
enter the name the email and some
password
add data
data send and if you check here
it
should be here wait
if refresh this
okay
okay wait a second
wait a second in the firebase config
yes but we are not getting the data here
so so so we are sending it
where is it where is it
we are sending the data with db instance
wait a sec add dock is it add dock yes
it's add dock
okay now let's try once more
let's make it nishant kumar too and then
add data
and
yes it's now getting saved here
it's nishant kumar 2 and the same email
password
so it's done we can now we now know how
to add data here
so next up is the
get data from firestore so we will
create and use effect hook
first a function but
the const get data
equals to
this error function and here we will
write our logic to get data
so we need
one more thing called get
docs we will just use
this get docs and pass the
instance here so the instance is called
this db instance
it will
specify the document
the document name and the database
so pass it
then simply create one use effect hook
or you can do it like this also so on
the button
just pass the function
so if we click the button of add data or
let's say get data
this function will run and it will get
our data
but we have to make it an asynchronous
function
and here we will have to update this
and we will store the inside one
variable so let's say const
uh
data equals to avoid got await get docs
db instance
and we can console this data like this
but we have to map it
i mean i will show you why
open the console click get data
we are getting all the data that we
cannot read so let me just filter it out
so in data we have the docs and we will
map it
it will take an item param
then we will simply return
dot dot item dot data
and then the id of the
item so it will be item dot id
now let's check get data
so we are getting three arrays sorry
three object of a three three objects in
an array
from here
so this is how very data in the fired
with firestore
so the next step is update data so let
me just
use the function here as well
or or okay fine so
um
okay let's now create a new function the
cons
update
data
and let me just
figure or just cut
okay let's
okay let me first do this
so
let's get back the addlock function
and add the here
not get data
okay what i'm doing
what the hell is i'm doing
so update data will be an arrow function
so we have the handle summit which is
add data so make it add data here
fine we're not running it at the moment
but it's fine
so to update data we will just use a
function called doc so it's not a
function
it's a
yes it's a function
so we will specify which document to
update so let's say
we will use a new variable called
data
to update
so it will take the dock and here we
will pass three things three things
so the database the collection name
sorry document what is it this the data
the database the collection name
and the id
so we have to specify which document to
edit whether it is this one or second or
third one
so we will get the id from this fields
so let me just create one new button
here at the bottom
here
but
but the thing is
okay what we can do is
let's map this data first
it's simple as well so we have to create
one state of
let's say array and set array
use state and array empty array
and then just set the set array here
only data we don't have to console it
then we will just map
compile with problems i does not define
fine we will address it later
so where is it array we have to map it
so let's map it here so array.map
it will take an
item param anything you want to write
you can write it here you will return
something
[Music]
so let's return cp or first attempt
as a parent
then
three p tags
so i will just say item dot name
email and password so it will look
through that array just like we did in
the angular version
so it will be an email now
and here it will be an
password so in the angular we have used
ng4 but here we are using this
array map
to
loop through the array
so in the button so we need one button
here as well so make a button
that will send data to that function
so button on click if you kick the
button
it will just send the data so we can
just say
what is the function name
update data
update data and we will just set the id
so item dot id
in the update field update data function
receive the id here
and it will work fine
so it's now here
so we are adding the which radio to
update
wait a sec
let's add our name here as well for the
button so update
if we refresh
okay we're not getting this here why
are a dot map it's here
okay let's remove this input fields and
see
or just comment this
okay we can have we have good data but
not this update
why
we are mapping the array and we are
returning it here
but we cannot see this
that's
why is that
okay okay okay
app header
if we choose the app header and
if we remove all this or just remove the
app header class
what is the thing here why we can't see
our
array mapping so here at map items
it will return some div and a button
inside
okay
just copy this or cut this
and remove all the things from here
one more div we need to close it and
then the
okay if we just open the console let's
see what we get
refresh
error is not here
we are setting it here
okay the problem is we're not setting it
here
okay that's a blender mistake i did
to revert all the things back
here so let's create one use effect hook
so use the effect so we are setting the
data but we are not loading it
when the app loads
so we will use the use effect hook here
and we will just pass
an empty array to make it an empty
dependency array
and we will just get data here
call the credit function inside and it
will work now you see we are writing all
these three fields
here
name email and password but but
but
so if we refresh
you cannot see our fields
if we are we are returning this item
array.map
getdata
okay okay okay
why we cannot see our fields item dot
name fine
the frame of the class here
okay now we are saying okay i guess it's
because the color of the font is white
so remove the color
and now we can see this
we can see our name our email and the
password
so let me just remove these things first
because we don't need at the moment
them
so if we click update on this field this
id will be passed down to this function
here and it will update so let's create
a
or let's up let's just
import some things here
so we need to import
update doc from firestore
so we also need one more to delete the
document so delete dock should be here
so to update doc we will just do
update data update
not data update doc
and we will pass data to update and the
data inside
so let's just make the
updation like this so we will change the
name as
first name should be not nishant kumar
just
nishant
let's add the email to be something else
so
okay if we copy and let's change some
small details
four four zero one two three
okay let's update this two only
and
if it is successful we will just
show and
message called
alert
data
updated
but if it fails it will catch it and say
it will take an error
and i will say console.log
error
or alert also
so if we now click the field of update
here
so this id will pass download the
function for this
what is it
for this property so wait
one more thing only just last thing
given hr tag here for the horizontal
line
so it's now
getting separated with this line
this is one field this is one field and
this is the last field
click update here this idea will be
passed to the function of update data
and
it will be passed to this
late variable called
let data to update
it is specifying which document target
first using the id parameter
and it's just updating the data using
this led variable and the
data i guess you know what i mean
if it's successful we will just have to
call the data
to get the updated data
if you click the first field they should
be nishant not nishant kumar and the
email will change to this
so let's update here
updated
and see it's now nishant and the email
has been changed as well
if we click or if we make this as
ashish
and
email is something
[Music]
is blah blah whatever so if you click
this
update this should change to rcs
and the image should be this
so update
changed you can also get the password so
if you make the password
to be
and string of abc
def
and update
this name will be the same
with the email and the password only
will change alone
update
updated
and the password has been changed now
here
so we can do it for that as well if we
update all the three fields will be
changed
see they are being changed
so
this is how data this is how we update
data in the fire store
the fourth one is called delete data so
we will just say const
delete
data
and here also it will take the id and
delete
data to update or make it data to delete
so it takes three params just like the
update dock
so we are importing delete dock
here and we will just have to pass
this
data to delete in the delete dock
function nothing else
and followed by this then in cash block
in case of success and errors
make it data deleted
and we have to pass the function in an
id
and button also
to make a button here
this will be delete
and on click of the button
we will just say
delete data and pass the item dot id
save
it is not defined so let's receive it
here in the
delete data function id
so we now have a delete button to delete
they should be deleted
deleted
and see it's not here if we check the
fire store
it's getting related in real time if we
delete the second one of aashish
delete it and it's not here and it's not
here as well
so we have added all the four methods of
cred operations adding deleting get data
and update data
creation
creating reading updating and deleting
so that's how
we operate we perform credo process in
react
and authentications using simile email
and email and password signup
you can also add one more signup method
called
google authentication or
github authentication
and
it is very easy
fine
so let me now
just comment
out or comment
name the comments from these codes and
save it
so we can just add data here and it will
show up in the bottom
so if we enter the name nishant kumar
some email and some
password if we
okay
add data so let me just
make the button here to be add data
where it is it
and the function name as add data
if we now click add data this will be
here
data sent
okay we have to use the read data here
first in the ad lock
so so so here is it
get data function
so if we add some more nishanth
one two three and all the things will be
same
sent
and it's here
so let me show you from the starting
delete
delete
add some data add data
then
and it's here let's make it as
rcs
this one should be ashish
four for zero at the right gmail.com or
just make it four to zero
charts of these i had data
then
it's here
and that's how we add data we can update
them
it's being updated
to this data we are adding here you can
make it dynamic by passing data to this
button and the function
sorry button sorry passing data to this
input fields
so i'm not going to do that
so that's how we do all the things in
firebase and react for firebase and
react
so let's learn how to authenticate a
next app with firebase we will use
google and github authentication plus
mln sign up we will also see how to send
data or receive data
it is also called credit operations in
next app so let's start
first thing to do is we have to create
our next app
so we can use this command npx create
next app latest
version
so this is just paste the command here
so let's add the name of the app so it
should be
next
crud
next
crud
and auth okay this looks fine
then add so it's downloading all the
packages from the
library from warsaw
then what we have to do is create a app
in
firebase so let's create it
so let's say next
auth grid
fine continue
we don't need analytics just create a
project here
so our project is getting created and
here also in the react app
so
wait a second or wait a minute then
continue
so our firebase project has been created
here
now what we have to do is create a app
so to create a app just type here
cred
auth
just type called fine
and here let's change the folder so
let's go into that
project folder which is called
next auth or net next cred and what
fine
so here we have pages we have index our
main page
we have our node modules that contains
all our dependencies
we have package.json that contains all
the list of packages
unlock i don't know what this is with
ignore take note on modules and all the
files they know what we've been pushed
to get
so now what you do is just
install firebase here
so open the terminal and just type npm i
fireways so we need this command
in order to firebase to work
meanwhile let's also create one file
here
so just create firebase config
and
pic.js
so this will contain all this
configuration data here so just copy
these things
and paste it here
remove the comments
okay
let me name the comments
so we are already importing the app here
so we need to export this from the
folder so say export construct
now we can use this app in our project
okay now we have to do in this home page
where is it
this one okay
but before that let's create a folder
which is known as
layout
layer out okay wait lay out slaves
inside create a
file called index.js
so this will contain our layout for all
the pages so we will create two page
so one is for registration one is for
the home page
so we don't need index right now so just
what can we do let's create two pages so
we already have index which will serve
as a home page so let's change it first
so we don't need all this code here so
remove them not this head
though we need the head remove
everything inside
the main tag
so so
remove it then save
and let's change the title here this
should be
next
crud auth
so crud stands for create read update
and delete
so continue to console here
now let's
define our
authentication methods
click get started here
we will use email password so enable
this
and we have to use the web okay we don't
need this password list we don't need
this right now so save it
plus let's add two more provider so
google enable
save
then let's also add github
we will use sign in for github and
google
so next one should be
github where is it this one
but for this we need a client id and
client secret
so just go to github.com
and go to settings
here we will have option developer
settings
open oauth apps
and let's create a new log in os app so
let's make it
crud auth
homepage url let's make it
localhost or this url here so first
let's start the app so we have to start
dive using
npm run
div
so it's learning on localhost 3000 so
just copy this url
and put it here in the homepage url
then we need the callback
which we should get from firebase so
copy this
authority
and paste it then register application
so it's returning as a client id
that we need to use it here
and a client secret so we need to
generate a new client secret
let me enter the password
okay it's wrong
i always forgot my password
it's still wrong let's try this
okay it's not fine
so we need this client secret so just
copy this using the copy symbol or icon
and paste it
then then save it
so we have enabled email and password
google and github
so so so what could we do now
so we are now opened here in the
localhost 3000 so let's create the
layouts page
before that let's give this home a title
of h1
which is called home
and it will show up here you see
it's showing up here
now let's do such what should we do now
to create one more page
it should be register
dot js
let's make it small r
fine one more we need
for
login dot js
so we have registered component and
login component
and in the index
we are fine here
so what i have to do create a layout
here
for the route the first thing to do is
importing
to import let's say
router
from next router
so we don't have to use react router
because it's not react it's next
and it's come it comes with the router
previously defined router i mean
now we have to create a function here so
called export
cons let's say
layout
so we're exporting this constant layout
and we can use it
this will accept some props
and
then inside a div we can just say
router okay wait not router we don't
need router we need link sorry
link
wait a second
import
link from next link
then we have to wrap our outside link
so
link it to
wait a second let me check what is the
command for linking
so when new
deployment
next link click this
okay
we have to use href
next
link href let's type the link for the
home page first
it should be just a slash for the first
add register register
and if we check our app or if we go to
register
so let's add a component here export
const
export not cons default
function register
then let's return something
let's return our dip first inside let's
add an h1 it should be saying
uh register
save
if we now go to register page
this
not this okay let's go to register page
now
we can see the register text here you
see it's now reflecting
let's let's do the same for the login
just make this says
log in and
this all is this also login
let's import the styles from index which
is called home.js so
this index i made
so first import styles
and add it here
we make it in the center this is all the
text
then then what can we do just add the
main here
so
in the div
just copy this div
till the footer and paste it here
just make this as
register
and just copy this again and
paste it here wait a second
here it is not defined so i guess we
have to input head as well
head
and image
in register page
now it's working fine
save and do the same for login
just change the text to login where is
it this one
and the
default function name login
now if we go to login we have to change
the add the import for login
but we have to add the link for login
so make it login
and let's add login here
so we have the login text here and
released text here add one more for the
home page
make it let's say home
and if we go to home we should see the
home text on the center
okay this is not found i guess why
so if we open home wait a second
it's not homemade index so let's change
it to
home.js
we have to change the input
okay it's automatically changed i guess
so so so we have now the layout here
and we are passing this so we need to
return the
data as well
so
wait a second okay it's working fine so
so okay
now this is done we have to import this
index sorry this firebase config file
in
the home page
so let's import so just say import
so it should say from
firebase config
so we
have to import the app so import app
from firebase config
in the home page
so it's working fine and we can see our
footer here you see
powered by virtual
now let's create our registered page
first then we will move to home page so
close all these things
so
in this page called register.js
let's add the styling
and the data
so let's just remove footer we don't
need it here
save
let's go to register page register
save
and it's here
so what we have to do now is we don't
need image import here
so let's import the firebase config file
here so import
app from firebase config
find auto imported
then we have to create
text inputs
to a text input so just create them so
we will say input
and they put it once more
so
what we have to do is we give this input
a class input a
placeholder off this should be email
and second one should be password
password
save we have email and password so let's
style them a little bit
so make this as the class name of
input
input input box in boot box fine
and here also in the second input
break it down
like this
and then save
okay
save it now let's style it a little bit
so in this
file called styles.home.model.css
just say
it
we have to just add
here
so input box
we can just say
let's say
width to be
200 pixels
but it will not work because vectors you
use
using styles so stay styles
dot
input
what is it the class
input box
save
okay
the problem here is we have to use it in
this camel case
then it will work
so just say
input box
so it's now weight wide
repeat the same for the second input for
password
save
they are both now wide
now let's add some height make it 30
pixels
fine
let's also give them a little bit space
between them so just say
margin
five pixels
now we have email and password fine this
looks better we can type email and type
password
so now what i do is create a state so
let's create two states
so first will be const let's say
email
and password
set email
you state
empty string
then const
password
password and set
password
then we have to just create
a use state hook here
empty string
now let's set them
so in the email we have to use on change
event on change
event it takes a event
and we can just do
a set email
event.target.value
and just copy and put the same here
but this time here this should be set
password
now we can get email and password if you
type here
also let's set the value so value should
be
the state of email
here so email and this one should be set
up password
wait wait wait wait
so value
this should be password
say when it's done
now we can get
our email password input properly
now let's create a function here
the const we should be
sign up
then we have to just import two
functions from firebase
so it should be import first add the
import then
from
firebase auth
so we will have to import two things
which is called
or get auth
and
sign in with or
sign
up
wait a second
register what is the method for
registering with email
it's it's uh first is sign up
with pop up
let me see
the method to sign in with
with
email password
it's not a register
it's not sign up
it's
wait a sec
let's search in google sign up
for firebase
sign up method
for
firebase
file by searching authentication
so so so let's go down
we have to use web
okay create user with email and password
fine i get it now
so we will use these two you see it's
here auth and create user with email and
password
then let's create an instance of auth so
just say const
auth equal to
get auth
save it
and just copy get create user with email
and password then you have to just pass
the auth
then the email
email and then the password
so now
if we are signed in we can just throw us
to
the page of home
if we sign up successfully
so we need to create a router instance
so just import
use router
use router
from next router
then then
create an instance of router so say
const router equal to
get router
router what is it sorry use router
use router
then we can just
say router dot
push to the
home page so if we see in the
uh where is it
in the layout page the route of home is
slash home
so it will push us back to that home
route so save
now we need to create a button here that
will send us to that page
so just import uh sorry just create a
button
and say
sign up
so we have the button here
let's style a button a little bit to
make it a class name of
tiles dot button
or button file
so in the button
class name we will just say
button
let's make width same as this or 100
pixels will be fine i guess let's try
100 fine
width
20 pixels
20
200
fine
let's add the
solid body what i'm doing this should be
height not width
too much so i guess it was right 20 was
right
so we have the button here
make it 30
fine also a cursor of pointer
if you hover this we will see the
pointer cuts are here
now what we can do is
we are using the signup button just add
the button on click event here on click
the button the function name
sign up
add it here
now let's add our email here and
password to sign up so nishant s
gmail.com and some password but before
that
make the type of password to be password
input type
password and this one is email
type
as email
so if we type a password here they
should be in dotted format we can't see
it so
let me get some password
one two three four five six one two six
sign up here
so if we
you'll see we are now on the home page
we have signed up
successfully
so now open the users in authentication
and we can see our email the provider is
email and password
so
we need to go back here
and create
two more
two more
what is it
options
one for google and one for github so
create two more buttons
button
it should be google
or just say
sign up
sorry sign up with
google
similarly one more button for github
[Music]
github
let's add some
set horizontal line between them
we use hr tag
and here also in between these buttons
fine
but but but
we are not saying properly because we
are using
the flexbox so it's being
it's it's being
shrink down to a dot here so fine it
doesn't matter
so
now we have to use google and github
signup buttons
so just repeat the styles here as well
and buttons
just format it like this
now we have done okay wait the problem
is we have to use
let's make it google or
button alternate
we have to use more
height here
so okay okay okay it looks fine doesn't
matter we are just using the fun we are
just showing the functionality not
styling the app
so
what we have to do is create one more
function or two more function
so first will be sign up with
google
second function will be github
it should be github
so we can use one we can use one
function to do the both
but
it will be complicated so i don't want
to make it complicated
so
we have to import
the methods for google signup and github
signup
so let's import
first is
google log provider the provider we have
to import and then github provider
fine these are the two things we need
here
so we have to specify the provider for
google so let's say
google provider equals to
this new
google auth provider
similarly do it for github
copy and paste
make google as github
git hub
and this one is github provider
so in
this function of google we can just say
uh we can just use this function called
okay we need one more thing here which
is called
sign
up with the
pop-up this one sign it will pop up
then we can just use this pop-up method
and we have to pass auth
this auth
where is it this auth and the provider
so first the button is google so we will
add google provider
this one
and we will record the
let's record the
yay what is it response response
and we can do the same here also so we
can record the response
so let's control it first
response
dot user we have to get the user id from
here and let's
console it here also
now this button of sign up with google
this function
we have to map it in this button here
so what we can do on this google button
just say
on click
this button
then just format the code here and put
the button at the bottom press enter
and do the same for github
and this one has bottom at bottom fine
so now if we click this button of
google it will open up a window that you
cannot see but i can only see because
i'm not recording that
window so open the console first to see
what we get on the console if we click
the button here
so open the console and see in this
providers we don't in the users we don't
have the
email we just have my email here
so let's sign up with google again
click we are seeing
a pop-up
and we have to use our email to sign up
click your email
and it will show us all the data inside
the user that we're getting in the
console here
you see
token or display name email
verified email is true or not is
anonymous or not we have the photo url
and all the things and if we see the
firebase auth it is let's refresh it
we should see our new email here and the
provider's google here you see it now
works fine
so the next thing we need to add github
so let's add it
so when a okay in this github provider
repeat the same method here
but this
provider of google it should be github
provider
github
save
and let's go up and just copy this
method const function
and add it to github
so on click
this github this sign with github here
so if we sign under github again let's
try click this button
okay you see we are still getting this
what is it a pop-up for github now not
google
so you see we are writing the error auth
account exists with different
credentials that is because we are
already using my email here you see
so we have to delete this first in order
to get up to work
because we can't create
account with two different to save
emails
so if we refresh now and try again
github
click your email or click authorize
you see it now works and if we open the
console we will see the provider of
github here
you see
the display name is same the email that
i used to add if we refresh this
or sorry free phrases or users
the provider is now github and my email
is now listed here
so we are done here i guess the auth is
now done
the last thing to do is
just push it to home page
here so just push to home
remove console.log or leave it
file
so if we now sign up we should be on the
home page so sign in to google again
sign up with google
and it will work because
we already have the same email here and
we are on the home page
so let's do one more thing here before
going
to the thread operation is
import use effect
from react
then create a use effect hook here at
the bottom of the functions
we use the effect function direct hook
and if we have two options here two
arguments or
parameters whatever first is the data
inside the function that we are going to
run
second we have no dependency array
so if it is empty it means it will run
only one time when we load our page
but if we have something inside let's
say a state
then this user facebook will run when
that state changes
so we have to do a check here so
here let's see let's just store our
token
inside a session storage
it's a good practice for authentication
so we can just say session storage
dot set item
we have to use the token
key and then the data so data is called
response dot user
dot aux token
and i am using this
special tool because it is getting it
gets destroyed when we close this tab
so if we close the tab we should be able
we should be logged out automatically
and we can't see that page
so do it same here and here
fine
we are now setting token in science
session
so go back and login again with google
and github or your email password
anything in this three
and
it's getting so if you open that
applications tab
which you see our you see we're seeing
our where is it
storage
this
next auth
okay we are not seeing this
at the second set item token
what is the problem here
what is okay we are saying it local host
3000 here this one
we are seeing the token here
so we have to create a check here
first let's get the token from
the storage when we load our application
so let
token
equals to
let's say system storage
we have to get that token here so get
item
the key name which is called token
so let's check here
if token exists so if we have a token
so if we don't have a token it won't
store it here and this will be empty
so if it is not empty if we have a token
here we can just throw back to
the home page using router.push
fine save it
so if we go back so we have a token here
and if we try to go back we should be
thrown back to this home page
you see
we can't go back to register because we
have took her inside here let's do the
same for the home page
so open that home page here
so open that home page and create a user
effect hook same as before
so import
use effect
from react and we are done
okay router is not defined so let's
create a auth
so it's from the router
first
import
use router
from
next router then create a const or let
router equals to
let's say
uh use router this import that we
imported right now
then it's fine so
now here we have to do something like
if we don't have the token we will just
push us back to
register page register
save
so we can't go back but let's try to
destroy the token now so delete it in
the session
application just delete this
so if we now refresh the page
we don't have we don't have the token so
we can't go back to or go forward to the
home page
because it will check if we have a token
or not
here
so our auth is now done
now let's move to the cred operations
using react router
sorry using next router
and next
so
sign up with google again
so we will do that things in our home
page here so open the home page and
let's start
so let's create two form based quickly
so in the home page we don't need that
h1 or just leave it doesn't matter
create two inputs so input
first this input and repeat it second
time here
so this should be off let's say
placeholder of
let's say this name and this one should
be
placeholder of
let's say age
so we have two fields name and age
let's give them some styles
so copy the styles
copy the class name and the style is
right
and just use styles dot
what is it this input box
input box
and here
so just repeat this once more here
okay let's name the footer because it's
checking the space in our app
and we can also clear this
console close the console
to have more space in our app
let's also add a button
button make it add
so now we can add data
using this button
so we can just use
the class name here as well
for the button that we created
so just add class name of in
style dot
button
here
and
just break this
fine
save
so now we have add button here that we
can use to add data to firebase
but before all that
we will store the data inside
this firestore database
only way to store data here
but we also have this real time
so create database here
okay create database make it test mode
because we are not in production we are
just testing the
functionalities so
server is done
enable it
so meanwhile import
a function called
it from firebase
pirate store
so input a function which is called get
fired store
wait a second the input is wrong
firebase fire store
fires
door file so import
get fire store
this function
and let's create one more export here so
export
let's create database
database
so we will use that git firestore
and we will just add this app inside to
initialize it
we have the
firebase app firebase what is it
this
data is created here and we can just add
data
so we can just
import this what is the database inside
home page
so we are importing it here
so just
we have inverting a whole app start also
input database here
fine
so now we have to create the instance of
the database i mean the collection
so we can just say const
collection
equal to not collection
let's say create
const
database
ref
equals to
so let's import collection here so to
create a collection
to import
collection from firebase firestore
then we will just create collection that
takes two things first is database
this database that we just imported and
second the collection name that we want
to give the collection
so let's make it
auth body
third data
so we are done here
we have created database ref here
and
we need one more function so const
add data
so database ref find we don't need this
so let's import a few things
here other than
the collection which is called add doc
so we need to use the add doc to add
data
and we have different functions for all
the
different methods so ad doc is used for
adding documents
we have redox study documents and other
things we will show in later
parts and in the later videos later
later later
so we will just use add doc
and we will just say
pass this database reference here
then the
email and password state sort email and
edge state here
so we're in two states so let's create
the const let's say name set name
setting use state
make it a string
empty string to initialize it similarly
for the
age so we're starting name and age here
h e h
so we can just
set the name and edge here in the inputs
so we can just say on change
and it will take a parameter called
event
event
and we just stored the
event
dot
target
dot value inside this set name value
and just copy and paste it again
make this as city cities
so if you type
the data here let's say name okay
used it is not defined
so import it here
define it use it now it will work
now we can type something here and in
the age
okay
so it's done so
in this input of h let's make it a
number number input type so just add
type of
number
because we can't add the
alphabetical characters here we can just
only add age
fine
so make this as input of text because
it's simple a text element here
and let's also add the value
this should be the state name
which is called name and here this
should be
uh value should be
it should be number one number it should
be age
save now let's try so just add the
button
to this function here
sorry add the function to the button
here
i am swiping things so
on click
swapping
add data fine
and now we have to pass data inside
this database so name should be the
name state
and it should be next should be age of
the state of age
so
if it is successful we will use thin
to denote that data has been sent so we
can throw an alert here
so we can say data sent
but if it fails we can just
use a catch block to throw the error
so we can just
show
the error so console.log
let's console it so console.error we can
just say
error
save and now let's try
so what we have to do here is additional
things to just set the values empty if
it adds something in the fire store
so we can set
name as empty
and set h as empty as well
okay not empty this should be null
because it's a number
and make the edges null here also
so now it's try enter my name nishant
is 25 then just add it here
okay data sent click ok and they are
being cleared but not this email not
this age because i don't know what's
wrong with this input type of number
it's fine with text but not number
so if we check the fire base
firestore we should get our data here
our name image
and the collection id sorry not
collection document id
so this id is called unique
this is id is unique so let's add one
more
let's say nissan
2. age 27
add
sent okay and it should be here
if we refresh this
this should be here
you see the second
collection
document is here with the name of nissan
2 and age 27
but the thing is we are adding a number
here
but
we are receiving string here
so we have to convert this name into a
string sorry convert this number into a
number a you know number so just wrap it
in a number
thing here
so now if we try again let's add nissan
3 or three
age 27 let's make it thousand
click add
send and here
this should be the new document
and okay
you see the edge is now number here it's
not string
so our add dock is done so now let's
move to the document
so for the re-document we need to input
a function here as well which is called
get docs
with an s
not
single dock
and
create a function here
so const
get
data
and make it an add-on function
then we have to just use
the schedule function
and we have to pass this
database reference and that's all to get
data
so we have to call this function first
so how to call this we have to call this
when our page loads
so in this use effect hook just pass it
here so if we have a token
we have to get data here like this fine
we can
also
create one check so if we have a token
only then we will call this
get data function which is always
so
we can we can
we are calling this function
so we have to make this function
asynchronous
and
make the size of it because we are using
a promise here
so we can just say dot then to record
the response we are getting
we can say response
and let's console it console
dot
log
response
save
to open the console now
and we are getting this data so if we
refresh it lets me refresh
so we are getting all this data here
where we are where this one but
there are a lot of data inside that we
cannot read properly
so we need to get the data in this
format so
this will this should be an array
this one should be an object and inside
objects we will have different
properties of name image
fine
so what we can do is we have to
map it
to get our data
so we can just respond the docs so we
have to map this blocks here
it takes a parameter or it takes a value
let's say
data
fine
so to return
the data
and the value of inside data which is
called data
so it's
peculiar so if we now save
we are getting these three objects here
in an array of objects
so we have an array which is this array
correct data
and inside we have two objects
one zero one and two and inside the
objects we have two properties of
agent name
in all these three objects
so let's also add the id here this
document id to differentiate between all
these three
so we have to wrap it inside a curly
bracket
and we have to merge it with the id
this object so we will just say id
and we can just say data dot id
now we can see our id as well here
you see we have this id of
hq zda whatever
the first one
and second one should be pm fz
and it's pmf z and third one is also
here
fine you see here
so
now i have to store this in an array
so create one add a state so const let's
say
uh fire data file data file good name
set fire data
so use state
there should be an array empty array
first
then we will have to just set it here
so just set this
close
now let's map our
this file show the date to see the data
here
in our ui
so this after the button
we will create a div here first
then we have to just say fire data
map
to get data inside this map
so we can just say data
to iterate over that and we have to
return some data here
so let's put it in a div
again
then we have to first use h1 for the
name so let's say
you have to target data object dot name
then second thing is
uh let's add a p tag it should be
data dot age so save
and now we can see our name and age
respectively like this
so let's make it h2 because okay it's
three it's too big
h3
now we can see our name
and the age respectively
let's make them in a single row
so we can just use styles
dot flex
then in the home dot module.css we can
just add
this flex
and we can just say
display of
flex also justify content
justify content
space evenly
fine but here it's not even so just make
this
justify content
space between
okay what about the third one why it is
not getting
reflected properly so let's check
the grid
so the main height is okay let's remove
all this
predefined
styles here
just leave input box
and the style is following it
okay okay okay okay
let's also add okay okay wait
this is freaking me fine it doesn't
matter i have to just add some margin
here
or just say
uh gap
to add the gap between the flex item to
gap 50 should be 10 pixels
okay now we have some gap here so we
don't need the just have a content okay
fine so we have the name
and the age
let's also use align items to align it
vertically
okay it's fine
so we can just add the name as well here
so name
text and
age text
so the name is nishantu and ages 27
just like firestore
so
rate is now done also
this read operation
okay what do we have imported here
that's wrong fine
so we're done name nh using red
operation we are getting all this data
here
now let's see how to update these fields
so to update
these fields we need a button adjacent
to this fields here to this name and age
so add a button
and give it a styles of but class names
of
the button style that we have in
home.model.css
this should be button so we can just say
styles
dot button
fine so we don't have anything so just
say update here
fine now we've click this
this have to send id to the function to
a function
so
create a function here first this should
be
const
update
fields
it should take the id parameter here
so receive it
and we will send id from this from this
button
so on click
we will just
send the id so just say
what is the data
dot id
now let's console it here
the console.log
id
so open the console now
if we click the button here of update
for the first field
okay we're not getting the id because we
have to use
arrow function here
like this
now it will work
so click the update of
nishant to
getting the id in this function here
in the bit field
this one and this one now let's update
the fields so we need a function here
first so it should be dock
and we have to update the dock
so dock will add dock will tell us which
for which field to edit in the fire
store
and this update dock will edit
so we have to add the dock first
so let's create let data
or
field to edit
so make this dock so it will select a
document
which takes
some parameters so first is
the database
second is
the collection name which is called
which is the collection name correct
data
so we can get it from this one
this one
this one
and the third thing we need is the id
fine so we have the failed edit now
which failed to edit
so second thing to do is we have to just
use update doc function
and pass this fail to edit first
parameter
second the thing we have to import so we
import the name
edit the name i mean
and
then we have to
give the updated
name
then let's add the age
and the bitter date
right so if it's successful we can just
throw a then
and we can just say console
dot
log
they should be
let's see like console let's add an
alert here
alert
data updated
but if it throws an error we can just
say catch
error
we can add a alert here or in console
log doesn't matter
or if it matters
if you are building an app
so
we have done these things here now let's
try to update so if you click update
here
it's updated but we are doing something
wrong
okay wait a second update fields
so we are doing this thing wrong because
we have to add this
function as get id
fine
we don't need this here we have to make
it on the
add button
so this
get
id they should be here
in this button of update
of get id
so if we click this we will get our id
so we have did something wrong here so
name is now but we don't have any name
in it so delete this
first one
because it's not it's not looking good
so if we refresh this this will be now
fine
so now we have to do is get this nishant
and a25 in this
input fields
so what we can do is we can
send our
name and age okay what should we do okay
we have to send the name and edge as
well so just say data dot name
and
data dot age
then
now then in this function
we have to receive it of get id so just
say
name is first and then we are adding h
so now let's set the name manage inside
this input
state so set name should be the
name
but okay just add
set name as name
and
set age as age
so now let's try to update click update
so we're getting the name and edge here
you see
but
we have to do one more thing so if we
click update here
this add button should be changed to
update
so let's do this
so create a
boolean value of berlin state called
is update and set
is
update
so use state it should be false
then we will set this update to true
when we click the button of update here
so where is it
so on this button click we are calling
this function
so just set this to true
now if it is true
then we will show a delay so update
button here
so where is the add button
so we can just say
if it is true i will show update button
or else the add button
to add the button here in the second
value second
check
and in the first
just make the add to update
update
so let's create one more function to
update the data
so this should be
const update
update
fields equal to error function
then we have to add this
field to edit
let's also create one more set for the
id
so copy this and add the constraint of
id here
id and set id
this should be null
because the id is number
so set id should be
this id so
to set the id we can just hit set id as
id
we are setting id
name and age here
so
in this update
fields just copy this
previous function update dock and we
have to add it here
just uncomment this and it will work
so this update dock taking is is taking
fail to edit and it's updating
here
so
this should be capital id for the state
so add the update field
to this button of
uh update so now let's try
to nishant and age 24 for the first
click update
and you see
the button is now changed to update here
add button
let's make it 26
click update
updated
and if you check here
okay the
the the
nissan is the name
so you see the age 26 now
so
here also i have to add the number
property before the age to convert it
into number
now if we try again
so if we make it 27 click update here
updated and the number is now number
sorry is the number
so it's working fine
so what we have to do now is just set
all this data to null
and empty string if we update
one more thing to do
we can't see our add button here
so to get see the i button we have to
set this set
is update to true
when we load our application or when we
click add data
okay not this if we refresh
okay it's here
so what we can do is
just okay it's fine leave it
so now we can update
and we can set it to false
when we are updated successfully
so we can just say set update
to false
so let's try now
let's update 225 page
click update
to update it and the button now add but
this number is not getting removed from
here because i don't know what's wrong
with the email with the number
input
so let's update this second thing second
value
to make the h27
and each just name this nishant update
updated
and it's reflecting here
you see the h27 and ms nishant
now let's add the delete function
so just add a button just like this
update
to delete this
so it should be here
fine just add a button of delete
the
delete
save
and it will do the same thing that the
bit is doing it will just pass the id
and we don't need the name image so we
have to just delete using this
get id function
so we're getting id here
and then we have to just
import one more thing which is called
delete dock
to delete the document
so simply create a function so const
delete
doc
movement file
then we have to just
use
this delete docs function
and pass it the
okay we have to use the
we'll do it first so create it
and just pass the fill to edit
we can response record this data using
then
and we will just throw an alert here
to say data
deleted
fine then just
cache it if it occurs any error here
so just say
alert
cannot delete
that
field
so let's try to delete the name of
nishan a25 click delete here
okay here
okay we have to add the
function in here as well in this delete
button
just wait a second
so okay the thing is we are using get id
to delete to update but to delete we
don't have to use get id we have just
used get document
and the pass id here
pass id and save id and just make this
as id here
now it will work
so refresh it again and let's check
delete the first field of nishant then
is 25
so deleted here you see we don't have
the
field of nishant and h25 here in the
firestore
but we can see it here
it means we are have refresh data
when we click delete so we can just call
the
get
data function
so click it again
so now we don't see any fields here
so we have to give us the get data
function
in the update field as well
here just paste it after the
uh alert
in this
where is it in the add field as well
so if we click or if we add it as let's
add data nishant a74
click add
send and it is reflecting here add
another name let's say ashish
a s h i s h
25
add
add sent
let's add third one
raju
and h27
add
here so we have three fields now let's
add one more last one
we should be there let's add
30 click add here
send
now we have four fields and in this fire
store we have four fields
four objects with nemanj properties so
now let's to try update this rajo field
so
the a should be 25 here make 25 click
update
and it now works in real time
it is getting updated properly let's
update aashish make the sob 2500
click update
this is now running 500 here
real time
let's try to delete nishant click this
date here
and this delete button
deleted
and we don't see the name of tishaan
there and neither in firebase
so
we have now done all the four operations
which are called
create for creating data
read for reading data
update for updating data and delete for
digital data which is also known as crud
so we have also added authentication
here so we can't go back unless we log
out
so let's create one more button last
button for log out here
because why not so
we can just create a div here
table
and make it a button inside this thing
so button
button make this says log out
log
out
save
so i have logger button here let's
create a function here
so const log out equals to
an arrow function then we have to just
destroy the token inside session
then we have to just
navigate to our home to register page so
we can just say
what can we say
we can say
uh
session storage
dot remove item let's add the key name
which is called
token
then we will just
return back to the home so router dot
push
to the registered page register
now we have to just add this logout
button in the button logout function in
this button
on click
log out
so click log out now
we have another registered page
and now we can't go back to the home
page because we have protective routes
in next.js
next js
if we sign up only then we can go to
that home page
sign up with my email account
see we are now seeing the home page here
with name of
his name sorry text of name and age and
all the data here
so
one more thing before going to sleep is
i have to create one more page for
logging in so let's create so let's say
login
or small login dot js
it's already existing in this location
okay we have already hit here
login
okay it's fine
so let's go to login page
so we can see login text here so we have
to create
the same thing that we did in register
so copy all the data and paste it in
login
just change
some
text
or
title so make it login
save
okay
reload it login
okay okay login
so here we don't need the okay we need
google and github fine does that matter
so but here we don't have to use
this size create user and password
create user with email password because
it's a login page we have to log in here
so let me show you what i mean so if you
go back to registered page
so let's add one random email so let's
say nishant
one two three at the gmail.com so let's
say
this is the email of any user let's add
a password one two three four five six
click sign up
so
it should be here in the fire store
authentication
firebase authentication
so we have this nishant one two three
and then gmail.com
and the password
so if we try to now
create the user with same email account
we can't able to create it
let's try it will throw an error so
nishan
one two three that it gmail.com
password add it here
let's open the console
okay let's also just
catch it here
so
just say catch
error
we can just say console
dot log
error dot code
to open the console
click sign up
you see
email
and already in use because we already
have the email here in this
fire so in this authentication tab in
this users
so you see we are getting this error
here also
so what we have to do is we have to log
in here not registered again
using same email
so
we can throw an error using alert so
just say
email
already exists
so to log in we have to create a login
function
here login
with google and sorry login with so it
should be sign in
with email and password
so just replace
create user with email and password with
this function called
sign in with email and password
now it will work
so if we refresh this
let's try again
let's add this email
nishant
one two three
gmail
dot com and the password
so make the text of sign up to log in
here
so this should be
sign in
now click sign in here
okay we need to be on the in
what is doing
login page
it's not login it's register
so now you add the email
here nishant as nishant
one two three internet gmail.com
the
password sign in
you can see we are now signed in here
but if we use the wrong email to sign in
that we are not registered properly we
will get an error
so we can just use the any email that we
have not registered so
let's try this one nishan
one two three four at the rate
gmail.com
password anything
sign in you see we are getting this
email called email already exists
okay wait
we have added the wrong
message here so it should be
emailed
does
not exist
and in the register we have to add
that previous
error message
already existing message
so just put in the cache block here
after this then
so sign in again
and you see email does not exist
because we don't have the nishant one
two three four here
so let's create it in the sign in page
sign up page mean
to email and the password
right
so we are using this nishant124 at the
right gmail.com and the password 1.6
sign up
so we are seeing all the data
now what if we use the wrong password
to sign in with again
so login
and if we refresh this we should able to
see one two three four account here
in authentication see we are getting
this so let's sign in
with this email but the password should
be wrong
so let's try this one two three
we will still get this error here called
email
does not exist because
we are not using custom error messages
here or we can just say
cannot login
if we get this error because we have
something wrong in the email or any in
the password
signing in so you can see cannot log in
because i think the password is wrong
so one two three four five six
sign in
now we can sign in here
so we have done all the functionalities
in our app starting from authentication
to credit operations
so now i'm logging out and going to
sleep